(audience clapping)
- Y'all have never met before?
- No.
- Yes.
- We're bringing people together.
- Did you say yes?
- I said yes. Yeah, we have five times.
- No, no.
- No, no, no. We never met.
(Kelly laughs)
But I didn't know post-Covid,
I don't know whether
to, in these situations,
are you supposed to fist
bump, or snog each other?
- I totally go in for a hug.
- Snogging is nice.
(Theo laughs)
- Is snogging, is snogging a kiss?
- Yeah. Snogging,
- Oh, okay.
- Snog's a British kiss. You know.
- [Kelley] Snog, why do you call it snog?
Because it sounds like,
not hot like a kiss.
- [Theo] Sounds something repulsive, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah. It's true. I don't
know what the definition is.
- [Kelly] Interesting.
I'm gonna Google that,
if only there were a way.
Well, congrats on "The White Lotus".
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] Yes.
(audience claps and cheers)
That's so, so very cool.
So did I hear this right?
You, you shoot this,
it's all shot on the, it
is the coast of Italy?
- In Sicily, yeah, yeah.
- Aww, I'm so jealous.
- Yeah.
- What a job.
- A tough one.
- Yeah.
- It's really like, "oh God, this sucks."
- That's incredible.
- Yeah, yeah. It was fun.
And, and we were there
for about six months, you know, 'cause...
- [Kelly] Poor you.
- Yeah.
- It's just, ah, I'm like really being
pushed through the ringer.
(Kelly laughs)
(Theo laughs)
- It's like where you go on vacation
but that's kind of funny 'cause
"White Lotus" in general.
- Yeah, it's about that, exactly.
- Yeah, yeah. Tell everybody
that hasn't seen it,
what, what is kind of the concept?
- It's kind of a
dissection of how terrible
the ultra wealthy can
be in these kind of very
bespoke holiday, you know,
holidays. But it's also,
but this one particularly
is a dissection of,
of sexual politics and gender
and stereotypes that gender roles have
and kind of dissecting them.
It's really interesting.
But beyond that, it's
quite a dark comedy, so.
- [Kelly] Dude, it's so huge.
I don't know anybody that
doesn't like the show.
- You've seen it, did
you see the first one?
- Yeah. It's a crazy show.
- It was fun.